[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant même mon incarnation dans ce corps
physique j'avais déjà une feuille de
route bien particulière
avant que je sois là ce qui existait
déjà c'était une opposition de culture
flagrante occidentale et orientale entre
ma lignée paternelle et maternelle
ce qui existait déjà c'était un grand
père grand maître de Kung-Fu un père
juste là bosse de boîte de nuit et
professeur de combat
ce qui existe ce qui existait déjà
c'était des parents séparés aussi malgré
un amour bien présent et d'une grossesse
donc voulue et même caché arrivé à une
seule petit truc salut enchanté
et ça maintenant c'est une force mais à
ce moment-là c'est ce qu'elle a engendré
les premières souffrances de ma vie
parce que pour les blancs j'allais être
en asiat et pour les Asiates j'allais
être en blanc donc en fait j'aurais ma
place nulle part jusqu'à ce que je la
crée
désolé il y a beaucoup d'émotions qui
vont arriver et je pense que vous allez
comprendre pourquoi
puis même si je comprends pas trop ce
que je peux ici entre une demi-sœur
blonde aux yeux bleus et l'autre brune
aux yeux vertes faut croire que je suis
plutôt content d'être là en fait avant
que j'arrive ma mère elle fait une
fausse couche d'un grand frère qui n'ira
jamais le jour donc forcément et donc
donner que j'arrive avec un service
trois pièces de qualité qui sont dit en
passant
on est contente tu vois elle est
détendue elle voulait un petit garçon
elle l'a en plus beau gosse de fou tu
vois en plus je sais pas si on a dans la
salle les petits derniers on connaît on
a un lien particulier avec la daronne on
est les chouchous
et à ce moment-là tout est parfait
mais je sais pas si vous remarquez en
fait je souris vraiment bon déjà parce
que Briday vous avez compris mais
fallait qu'il allait avoir du bordel qui
allait arriver comme si j'allais avoir
besoin de ce sourire dans la vie que
j'allais me construire comme si je
savais que j'allais avoir besoin de
positivité
comme ça
comme si ma mère elle a suicidé quelques
années plus tard tu as une dépression
qui a décidé de vaincre en silence comme
si j'allais perdre tous mes repères être
bouger des colles en école et subir du
racisme avant même de perdre mes dents
de lait
comme si j'allais grandir dans
l'incompréhension la plus totale et le
manque du pilier le plus important pour
la construction d'un petit être qui
vient à peine d'avoir conscience de
lui-même
comme si mon grand-père la reviendra à
quelques années plus tard parce qu'il se
remettra jamais de la perte de sa fille
donc dans la tête
comme si j'avais trouvé du repère et du
réconfort et un symbole féminin auprès
de ma grand-mère paternelle avec qui
j'ai vécu jusqu'au moment où elle part
faire une prise de sang pour ne jamais
revenir suite à une erreur médicale
pendant cette même période je passais
mon baccalauréat et j'apprends que ma
copine de l'époque me trompe
[Musique]
car ce sourire
tu en auras besoin si je sais pas encore
mais dans ton sang coule toi aussi les
gènes de cette dépression et ses pensées
suicidaires jusque là totalement inconnu
maintenant que vous en savez un petit
peu plus sur l'histoire de ce petit truc
je me présente je m'appelle Tristan de
feuille vanque j'ai 25 ans et je suis
principalement connu sur Youtube pour
apprendre expérimenter dans tous les
domaines notamment à travers ma série de
vidéos practice max il y en a qui
suivent un peu hésitez pas à faire un
peu de bruit parce que un peu de stress
tout ça
[Applaudissements]
et si je suis là aujourd'hui c'est pas
pour booster mon ego en étalant tous les
succès de ma ville si je suis là
aujourd'hui c'est pour vous partager ce
que j'ai appris d'un chemin de vie
vraiment particulier qui a pas demandé
l'autorisation de ce petit truc pour
faire de lui un futur black sheep
et mon frère à Black Sheep il me dit que
il y en a d'autres dans la salle qui ont
vécu des languettes il y en a d'autres
qui sont sentis seuls qui ont eu mal qui
sont senti différents à un moment donné
alors je leur parle plus
particulièrement que ce soit dans la
salle ou derrière l'écran
commençons par parler des souffrances
que tout ça ça a généré dès qu'on
commence à travailler sur soi on tombe
très vite sur les travaux de recherche
du psychiatre américain John Pierrakos
au sujet des cinq blessures de l'âme
et dans l'idée on a l'abandon la
trahison humiliation le rejet tout ça
très complexe de rentrer dans le détail
en si peu de temps donc la seule chose
qu'il faut pour retenir tout ça c'est
qu'on les a tous encodés en nous pardon
à des degrés différents et si pour
l'instant tu le sais pas tu le consensus
se passe et pas que tu es hors normes
c'est juste que c'est caché quelque part
un peu plus loin dans ton inconscient
l'avantage avec mon chemin de vie c'est
que je me suis mangé tout ça d'un coup
donc à la suite de ça il y a que deux
chemins qui s'offrent à toi soit on fait
une force tu survis tant mieux soit tu
sombres
et tu peux potentiellement littéralement
crever comme mon grand-père
parlons un petit peu de maintenant que
vous avez compris que la vie n'a pas été
très tendre avec moi on va essayer de
relativiser un petit peu
on va voir pourquoi il s'est passé tout
ça et comment ça
a construit le clip nous allons en face
de vous du coup
déjà la première chose à comprendre une
fois que on aura travaillé sur ces 5
blessures de l'âme que je vous invite
d'ailleurs de ouf à faire parce que une
fois que vous conscientiez ça ça vous
permet d'accélérer votre guérison et
juste de conscientiser une plante
principale inconscientes
la seconde étape aussi de physique ça
puisse paraître c'est d'apprendre à se
connaître et pour ça il y a rien de
mieux que d'être dans l'énergie du fer
FAI r e il y a rien de mieux que d'être
dans l'action d'être en mouvement
pourquoi de 1 parce que vous aurez même
pas le temps ni l'énergie disponible
pour nourrir votre douleur et continuer
de la trimballer avec vous de la
tracasser et de deux parce que vous
allez apprendre à vous découvrir et
comme disait Bruce Lee toute forme de
connaissances devient finalement
connaissance de soi
donc en gros plus tu testes des trucs
plus tu connais plus tu te connais plus
expérimente plus tu conscientises qui
raisonne en toi aussi bien positivement
que négativement et plus tu vas petit à
petit le faire passer du stade
d'inconscient je parle de du coup plus
tu vas petit à petit les conscientiser
en les ramenant dans ton inconscient et
ça c'est entre autres le processus
d'individuation de Carl gustavion
notamment soutenu par mon auteur préféré
et cartoler donc quoi qu'il t'arrive et
peu importe dans quel bas de mot tu
puisses être rappelle-toi que le
meilleur truc que tu puisses faire pour
toi et pour te sauver c'est d'être dans
l'action beaucoup de théories un peu de
concret tu viens de te faire plaquer au
lieu d'être en PLS dans ton lit à soyez
plus sur tinder pour essayer de
compenser ce mon café de 6 je
t'inviterai plus à sortir allez faire
des rencontres allez tester des sports
des disciplines des loisirs artistiques
peu importe mais elle est expérimenter
des trucs que tu as jamais expérimenté
pour ressentir des émotions que tu as
jamais ressenti en plus il y a un truc
très stylé dans notre corps très bien
fait ça s'appelle la neuroplasticité et
c'est juste en terme un peu barbare pour
dire que ton cerveau est capable de se
restructurer si tu le sollicites pour en
gros plus tu essayes des trucs plus tu
crées des nouvelles connexions
neuronales en créant des nouvelles
neurones ça s'appelle la neuro-génèse
donc neurologiquement parlant tu crées
littéralement des nouveaux chemins de
vie et crois-moi quand tu es habitué à
être orienté vers la douleur avoir une
option une petite porte de sortie ça
fait du bien
la deuxième chose que j'aimerais
partager avec vous aujourd'hui c'est un
point d'un courant de pensée
philosophique qui m'a énormément impacté
certaines personnes dépriment quand il
pleut d'autres sont heureuses pour leurs
fleurs certaines personnes vont blâmer
une situation de ce qu'elle est d'autres
vont comprendre que la situation est
juste une situation et que c'est
peut-être notre manière de nous
positionner face à celle-ci qui est
important c'est peut-être notre
perception de celle-ci qui est un porte
réellement j'aime bien dire que la vie
fait 10% ce qui nous arrive et 90%.
comment on se positionne face à ça
et ça c'est le principe de base du
stoïcisme un courant de pensée
principalement développé par l'empereur
romain Marc Aurèle dont je vais résumer
les concepts très simplement
[Musique]
avec cette phrase tu peux amener un âne
à la rivière mais tu peux pas le forcer
à boire
et il compte centre toi seulement sur ce
sur quoi tu as le contrôle concentre-toi
seulement sur ce sur quoi tu peux
prendre des responsabilités pas sur les
résultats patience sur les situations
pas sur les événements
exemple concret dans ma vie j'ai pas
trop eu mon mot à dire sur tous ces
événements douloureux qui me sont tombés
dessus les uns à la suite des autres par
contre j'ai pu contrôler mes mots mes
pensées mes actions ma gratitude les
thérapeutes que j'ai vu les livres que
j'ai lu tout ça donc on se concentre sur
ça et tout sur quoi tu n'as pas le
contrôle ça dégage c'est plus simple à
dire qu'à faire mais une fois que tu
commences à implémenter ça dans ta vie
il y a beaucoup de choses qui commencent
à se passer dans ton petit crâne encore
plus si tu mixes ça avec la
neuroplasticité d'avant et de comprendre
et d'accepter ce principe c'est en
grande partie ce qui m'a permis de faire
mon deuil à 100% parce que si on va un
petit peu plus loin on comprend qu'on ne
peut pas aider quelqu'un qui ne veut pas
réellement être aidé
donc aussi dur que ce soit ça a été
extrêmement douloureux de l'accepter
mais c'est ce qui m'a permis de faire
mon deuil à son pour cent
le troisième point que j'aimerais
partager avec vous c'est la gratitude
vous en faites pas il y a pas besoin
d'avoir tatoué dans le cou pour que vous
puissiez l'appliquer dans votre vie bien
que ce soit un bon rappel par gratitude
j'entends le fait de dire merci merci à
la vie merci à l'univers merci à la
source Dieu peu importe en fonction de
tes croyances on s'en fout comment tu
l'appelles mais juste être reconnaissant
après le piège de la gratitude c'est
qu'on a tendance à être reconnaissant de
tout ce qu'on a sans considérer la
chance de pas avoir eu ce qu'on a pas
un peu comme le symbolisme
en fait si tu considères tous les
événements positifs qui sont arrivés il
faut aussi savoir considérer tous ces
événements négatifs parce que quand on
prend un peu de recul au final positif
négatif c'est une question
d'interprétation et de jugement
personnel sauf qu'en langage des oiseaux
on apprend que celui qui juge non
ok je vois que j'en ai perdu deux trois
dans l'audience je vais vous ramener
très vite sur Terre avec un truc que
vous connaissez tous c'est bon c'est bon
Tic-Toc ok je crois que ça me capte un
peu plus il y a pas longtemps il y a ce
petit garçon qui a fait un son qui a
traîne des partout dans le monde et ça
peut ultra plaisir parce que derrière
ces paroles très simples et très
simpliste
se cache une réelle vérité je suis pas
chanteur donc calmez-vous pour les
jugements mais pour vous remettre l'air
dans la tête ça fait un truc de style
je vous ai dit que c'était pas chanteur
d'accord c'est juste pour que vous
l'aviez dans votre tête voilà
et en fait le truc qui est très stylé
avec cette chanson c'est qui résume tout
il résume tout pour ceux qui ont ce type
les cours d'anglais LV1 au collège dieu
merci pour le soleil merci pour la pluie
merci pour la joie merci pour la douleur
et comprendre ça et surtout l'accepter
comprendre que tout ce qui nous partout
tout ce qui nous entoure tout est
question de dualité c'est vraiment ce
qui m'a permis de tout casser par la
suite plus tu iras loin dans le spectre
de la souffrance plus tu pourras aller
loin dans le spectre du bonheur une fois
ce trauma digéré
plus
même chose pour la météo en fait plus il
fait mauvais plus il pourra faire beau
une fois que l'orage sera passé plus
l'arc-en-ciel pourrait être beau
je sais pas si j'ai le temps de
développer tous les points qui ont fait
que je suis littéralement devenu
l'archétype de tout ce qui aurait sauvé
ma mère mon grand-père ma grand-mère
mais pour vous les résumer
ma mère est partie principalement pour
une dépression et ce qui me suivent sur
Youtube le savent j'essaie d'être la
mettre le plus positif possible et de
toujours vous montrer qu'on peut tout
faire en sortant les doigts il y a pas
longtemps j'ai conscientisé le fait que
si je fais tout ça si je suis accroché
sur le net d'un avion qui fait des
loopings sans expérience ou que je me
jette d'hélicoptère à 5000 mètres
d'altitude concernant c'est pour me
faire kiffer mais inconsciemment c'est
parce qu'il y a une part d'elle qui vit
à travers moi déjà parce que je partage
50% de ces cellules mais surtout parce
que j'aimerais bien donner le sourire à
quelqu'un qui l'aurait perdu et ça c'est
un peu plus loin dans l'inconscient le
deuxième point de son départ prématuré
c'était le manque d'argent pas besoin de
vous faire un film vous êtes tous en
école de commerce vous savez les
youtubeurs sont pétés dessus voilà on
fait le point plus sérieusement en fait
inconsciemment depuis que tu gosses j'ai
toujours eu ce Drive et ce truc qui m'a
poussé à faire des sous et entreprendre
super tôt c'est pour ça que j'ai
confondé une boîte avec mon meilleur
pote qui a fait du coup 12 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires en 4 ans
c'est pour ça que j'ai réussi et eu la
force et la résidence de faire cette
chaîne Youtube qui va bientôt fêter 5
millions d'abonnés tout ça parce que
depuis tout petit je me dis
inconsciemment il faut pas faire comme
maman sur ça
problème solution et le dernier point
c'était sa mauvaise santé et un cancer
qu'elle pensait avoir
longue story show j'ai 10 ans plus tard
toujours pour jour et ça c'est fou elle
est partie 31 août 2005 elle contient un
août 2015 et j'intègre une formation de
coach sportif ultra privée un an plus
tard je commence à vendre des programmes
en ligne et du coup à aider impacter la
santé de santé de personnes à mon
échelle et trois ans plus tard je
sortirai mon premier livre qui résumera
toutes mes connaissances toutes mes tous
mes conseils toutes mes données pour
faire plus de muscles moins gras et tout
simplement être en meilleure santé de
manière globale puis on va plus grande
surprise ça viendra un best-seller ce
sera vendu des milliers d'exemplaires et
ça générera près de 250000 euros de
vente donc plutôt pas mal merci maman
en bref tout ça pour vous dire que tous
ces événements douloureux qui me sont
arrivés qu'on a tendance à catégoriser
de négatif le sont arrivés pour une
bonne raison et au même stade que tout
ça ça m'a permis d'être la meilleure
version de moi tout ce qui viendra
titiller votre corps de souffrance ça
sera exactement la même chose pour vous
donc à l'image de cette élastique plus
on va vous soumettre un stress plus on
va vous attirer plus on va vous mettre
la pression plus vous allez en magasiner
de la force et de l'énergie cinétique je
me rappelle cours de techno et plus vous
pourrez rebondir à aller de l'avant par
contre à l'image d'élastique va falloir
apprendre à vous connaître parce que si
vous connaissez pas vos limites vous
pourriez suivre le même chemin avec ma
mère ou mon grand-père
s'il y a une seule chose que j'aimerais
que vous reteniez de cette ex
c'est rappelez-vous juste
qu'inconsciemment vous avez tous grandi
en développant les traits de caractère
de ce qui aurait sauvé vos parents
soyez en fier
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]